[Music]
well if you haven't checked out area 15
yet
now is the perfect time because they've
opened nine new immersive experiences
and rocky got a sneak peek of one that
makes its official debut tonight
welcome to emporium arcade farm here
with the owner danny you are the owner
of this joint and i have to challenge
you
to a game of basketball come on let's do
it so we need so we need four tokens
right for this game
that's right and a drink from the full
bar that doesn't hurt
because this is more like a club arcade
right rather than a regular
arcade yeah we got djs on the weekends
full dance party we got a full arcade
lineup
classics from the 80s and 90s video
games pinball machines skee-ball
basketball foosball pool tables
everything to have fun with while you're
hanging out with friends and drinking
i love that and you said you also can
host like corporate events here too
absolutely we do corporate events
uh birthday parties all sorts of stuff
adult birthday parties we're an adult
venue so
it's a great place to hang out with
friends or bring your company or dj's on
the weekend
that's right full dance party so how do
you keep people safe here
we take covet super seriously here
everyone all our staff wears masks all
our customers wear masks when they're at
the games and walking around
we have all our tables spread out
socially distanced we'll keep the game
spread out a little bit
and keep it clean and sanitary
daddy come on
come on now that was fun that was so
much fun i also want to know more about
this art on the wall
yeah absolutely all our locations uh
we're in chicago and the san francisco
bay
as well we always work with the local
community to find the best local artists
up and coming fresh talent to come in
got 10 plus artists in this
location here they were all put together
by unravel artistic consulting
which is a local consulting company that
friends of mine
and uh just really pops and came out
awesome yeah
this is so vegas i love it here already
you guys got to come down to emporium
i think i think i went around too we
tied so i'm trying to beat you danny i
don't know i think
a tie is like a win for me so all right
i'll take it i'll take it i'll send it
back to you guys